digital series which provides fans with
a day in the life of some of the top
athletes across all sports as they work
under our new social distancing world
you can find daily shows on the NBC
Sports You Tube channel NBC Sports comm
and the NBC sports app so you know that
the draft is coming it's going to happen
there's no point arguing against it it's
going to happen and the NFL is realizing
as it goes Peter that there are gonna be
some very real impediments to making the
draft happen the way that they would
like it to on Tuesday the NFL announced
during the conference call with
reporters after the league meeting by
conference called that they would allow
small war rooms of up to ten and there
had to be proper practices social
distancing and hand cleaning etc and I
think somebody for realized wait a
minute in most states now there's a stay
at home order and there's no exception
for NFL teams need to get together to
draft their players and if you have only
one state where the NFL does business
that says sorry NFL we're not going to
give you a dispensation from the
stay-at-home order you have a
competitive imbalance and the NFL sent a
memo yesterday it was first obtained by
espn.com explaining that there's going
to be one of two approaches one teams
will be allowed to assemble at their
facilities up to ten with appropriate
social distancing measures or -
everybody's gonna have to be at home and
Peter I think frankly that memo is the
first step at saving some face because
they got over their skis on Tuesday with
this up to ten people can get together
there's no way they're going to get
permission from every state where
there's a stay-at-home order to allow
their employees to gather at the team
facilities this is not an essential
function it's essential to the NFL teams
it's not essential from the perspective
of what is and isn't allowed when it
comes to staying at home versus leaving
your home Mike I don't see how I don't
see how allan sills and and and and
anybody who because basically what they
would have to do what the NFL would have
to do is you know for instance the New
York Giants and
Jetts who do business in new jersey they
would have to make some sort of appeal
to the governor of New Jersey or to
somebody in state government to say we
would like to open our building to 210
people or less for a three-day period in
order to hold the draft now just
multiply that mic times you know times
31 hour times thirty-two excuse me you
know and basically what if gavin newsom
the governor of california tells the
rams you can't go into your building in
Thousand Oaks tells the chargers they
can't go into their building in Orange
County and the 49ers you can't go into
your building in Santa Clara so so it
Roger Goodell has made it clear that if
one team doesn't have the advantage of
working in its facilities that no teams
will and and the NFL like my feeling is
right now they should just start to plan
on having these things in people's homes
and let's just say right now that even
with the stay at home order would the
NFL or with would the public you know
fathers mothers in these states would
they allow gatherings of ten in private
homes that's what I don't know yet
that's what is unclear but Mike we're
also looking you know Kevin damoff of
the rams
I was on a call with him yesterday and
one of the things he's talking about is
you know we're in this brave new world
with all this video conferencing we got
to be sure that we've got we've got good
encryption with all of this video
conferencing because obviously if the
Rams have a bunch of people on on a
video conference on the night of the
draft they don't want the 49ers being
able to say hey let's listen into it the
Rams can do and look I know nothing
about the security of these things but
if NFL teams are worried about the
encryption of this this is another
little factor why Michael bid will the
owner the Cardinals told me the other
day
hey our IT guys have been our MVPs this
offseason and so the IT guys are gonna
have to do even more in the next three
weeks to make sure that nobody is spying
on the video conferences during the
draft so there are 900 little little
things like that that NFL teams have to
take care of before the draft you know I
don't want to cast aspersion or throw
stones but again this is the challenge
of our lifetimes and it's incumbent on
all of us to do what is right and
responsible the fact that as of Tuesday
there was a blind spot for the NFL as it
relates to the many stay at home orders
and the obvious conflict between the
stay-at-home orders and the desire to
assemble in groups of up to 10 for the
draft it tells me that somebody isn't
thinking these things through Peter the
way that they should and if they're not
thinking things through on something
that is obvious that we know about what
else are they not thinking through the
way they should behind the curtain it's
alarming it's concerning and it's all
the more reason for the NFL to find a
way to stand up and start showing
leadership and look Peter I even if they
get permission from all of the states in
which the NFL does business to gather at
their team facilities we go back to what
we talked about in the last segment what
kind of message does that send when we
are expecting millions of people to stay
home who to them their jobs are
essential to them they're thinking why
can't we get together for a meeting at
our accounting firm or at our law firm
or at our advertising firm or wherever
why can't we have a meeting the NFL's
having their meeting their meetings is
important to them as our meeting is to
us so this is another example where the
NFL has to take a step back and realize
the same rules apply to everyone and if
the NFL acts like the rules are
different for them other people are
going to say well why are we worried
about these rules yeah that's why I
think Mike as as painful as it is the
NFL is probably going to have to very
strongly consider having a head coach in
his house the general manager in his
house the scouts in their house and
all be connected virtually and I also
think that that's one of the reasons why
you know right now as the NFL looks at
it there's a ten-minute drafting window
in the first round seven minutes in the
second round are second and third right
and then five minutes in four through
seven excuse me and so at this point I
think one of the things that you look at
Mike is the the fact that I think you're
gonna have to look at expanding those
those windows and I think particularly
in the early rounds when most teams
really talk a lot they talk trade a lot
I mean the last time I was in a draft
room for the for the weekend was 2017
and you know the San Francisco 49ers
made 19 they tried with 19 different
teams to trade up into the first round
good thing they didn't because they were
trying to trade up for Rueben foster but
but that is what so many teams do so
I've already heard from one team that
you know speaking and I don't want to
get too far off the topic because I know
your point here but I've already talked
to one team that is thinking about
assigning to different members of their
organization like okay director of
college scouting you are going to have
the following X number of teams that you
are going to check in with we're gonna
send out a note hey if you want to talk
your first point of contact in our
organization will be John Doe our
director of pro personnel and then to
six other teams your first point of
contact will be Jack Smith our director
of college scouting so those are the
kind of things that I believe at the end
of the day are probably gonna have to be
done yeah I agree with you completely
and it's that kind of creativity that
the teams who get it the teams who are
accustomed to having grateful lot of
football operations they're gonna figure
this out and they're going to be ready
to go but it will create more challenges
and I got no
problem with more time between pics what
else are we doing right I don't care
if the first round is a little bit
longer or rounds two and three take more
it's that's one of the reasons why
they're going through with this it's
giving those of us who are adhering to
the requirement to stay at home
something we can number one look forward
to and number two spend a lot of time
following and watching on TV
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports